wenn es uns schlecht geht dann ist er
plötzlich wieder gut genug
gott und gerade geht es vielen schlecht
manche leute sind schwerkrank sterben
gar andere sind überfordert und
verunsichert was ich spende trost in
dieser zeit und wie sorgt man dafür dass
allein sein nichts einsamkeit wird das
möchte ich von niklaus peter pfarrer im
fraumünster in zürich wissen
guten tag herr peter schön sind sie
heute hier ja eher peter wie ist es bei
ihnen beten sie im moment häufiger nein
nicht häufiger sondern ich bete rein das
bild gehört zu grundhaltung aber es ist
nicht so dass ich jetzt die krise bin
und deshalb denkt jetzt muss ich
häufiger bieten sondern ich glaube es
ist ganz wichtig dass man sich sammeln
kann und das gebet ist eigentlich dass
es gewillt ist nicht so dass man gott
unter druck setzt mit irgendwelchen
wünschen menschen in solchen krisen
erfahrungen reagieren ja stärker auf
existenzielle fragen oder sind
ansprechbarer dafür denken sie das wird
sich auch in zukunft durch diese
krisenerfahrung jetzt diese sehnsucht
wecken oder ist das einfach romantische
vorstellung
also ich will so sagen not lehrt beten
theologie ist keine gute theorie das
heißt wenn man jemand der ohne religion
ohne spiritualität durchs leben geht da
wird nicht plötzlich religiös wenn er
solche dinge erfährt oder wenn man
religiös wird dann vielleicht auf eine
problematische seite aber was heißt das
auf eine problematische weise aber als
dann so eine instrumentelle religiosität
ist jetzt soll gott mir helfen so ich
glaube es aber das ist anders ich glaube
es ist so dass eine krise schüttelt uns
durch und das gibt wie immer zwei
möglichkeiten
so sehe ich auch heute was
reaktionsweisen sind die einen menschen
die entwickeln eher schlechte gerückt
eigenschaften die spitzen sich zu
genauester käufe oder besserwisser
treten auf machtgehabe aber ich habe
sehr viele erfahrungen in die richtung
des menschen sensibler werden dass sie
solidarischer werden
in diesem sinne glaube ich kann eine
solche krise auf eine gute weise zum
nachdenklichkeit führen kann dazu führen
dass man plötzlich sich besinnt was ist
eigentlich das wichtige im leben was man
eher unwichtige dinge also in diesem
sinne ist ja nicht ganz neu was ich sage
und trotzdem es kann eine chance sein
das heißt oder vielleicht mit einem
englischen ausdruck gesagt ist die
chance 2000 into madison und das heißt
dass man plötzlich gifte schwieriges in
medizin umwandeln kann
das wäre eine religiöse haltung glaube
ich jetzt könnte er dann heißen das
dasein anfang ist in die die eigene
religiosität zu entdecken
das glaube ich auch und ich denke auch
dass in großen krisensituationen für die
einen menschen genau das ein impuls war
man sieht ja auch in der theologie
geschichte in der kirchengeschichte das
innere wendungen von menschen verbunden
sind mit solchen extrem erfahrungen
letzte woche hat pabst franziskus
außerordentlich den segen urbi et orbi
gesprochen er war ganz alleine auf dem
petersplatz es hat geregnet die glocken
haben geläutet ich fand es unglaublich
eindrücklich sehen es hier
was denken sie schaut so hoffnung aus
ich habe mir das auch angeschaut und
waren auch sehr beeindruckt
ich war sehr beeindruckt weil er auf
eine so ruhige stilsichere weise aber
eben nicht nur den segen gesprochen hat
sondern warm klar geprägt hat er hat
über die stellung des see sturms hat er
eine predigt gehalten
und da hat man gemerkt was ihre gute
religion kann
sie kann nämlich uns mit geschichten
sprache geben um das zu reflektieren was
wir erfahren sie kann uns möglichkeiten
gegen ängste auszudrücken dieser predigt
sehr eindrücklich er davon spricht wie
die menschen jetzt ängste haben
empfinden sich verlassen fühlen als
wären sie auf hoher see quaas er auch ja
ja und ich habe ich finde das hat ja
sehr eindrücklich gemacht sehr
stilsicher wie man das als protestant
bei den katholiken auf eine weise
beobachten manchmal bisschen neidisch
werden
aber können sie auch sowas hoffnung
danach schöpfen also sie denken damit da
hat er etwas gemacht dass den leuten
wirklich auch die hoffnung zurück geben
kann ist glaube ich das glaube ich
und zwar deshalb weil er ihnen sprache
gibt eine ihnen deutung kategorien gehen
weil er ihnen etwas an die hand gibt wo
sie selber dann etwas damit machen
können diesem sinne bin ich beeindruckt
und erfreut dass ich das gesehen was ich
immer wieder von leuten lese oder höre
die selber zu kämpfen haben mit dem
ganzen übel dieser welt ist ja auch eine
frage die die theologie seit jeher
umtreibt also wie kann es sein dass ein
allmächtiger gott so viel übles so viel
missgunst hass krieg und so weiter in
der welt zulässt wenn er doch eben
allmächtig ist und das kommt natürlich
in solchen krisenzeiten umso mehr auf
diese sogenannte theodizee frage wie
gehen sie selber damit um oder finden
sie das ist die richtige frage in dieser
zeit die frage wie man die frage stellen
soll
und ich glaube wenn man all macht ins
zentrum setzt das man nachts
falschen wege also wenn wir jetzt mit in
der passionszeit wenn wir darüber
nachdenken dass die körner zählung die
ist dass gott mit diesem jesus von
nazareth dem friedensprojekt einen weg
mitgeht ins leiden hinein und das leiden
überwindet dann bekommt man eine
richtige perspektive auf diese fragen
nämlich nicht ob der allmächtige gott
dies oder jenes zulässt dass in eher
philosophische fragen sondern es die
frage des glaubens dass man sagt wo sind
dinge wo ich selber aufgerufen in
schritte mitzugehen solidarisch zu
werden
in diesem sinne würde ich sagen sollte
man nicht quasi im sessel mit großer
distanz über diese fragen nachdenken
sondern man sollte darüber nachdenken
was in diesen geschichten was in diesem
gottes geschichten erzählt wird über
unsere verletzlichkeit aber auch was
erzählt wird wie wir schwieriges
überwinden können und das sind die kerne
zählung in der bibel aber ist dann damit
schon die frage beantwortet trotzdem
kann man ja darunter leiden trotzdem
kann man sagen wie ist es möglich dass
diese welt so geschaffen wurde wenn es
denn gott gibt dass gott sie so
geschaffen hat dass die menschen
dermaßen darin leiden ich meine was
jetzt sagen könnte man auch sagen ist
aus einer gewissen lage gesprochen
privilegiert man kann schon sagen ja
man sitzt nicht quasi einfach im sessel
und schaut so von außen drauf und jetzt
tu mal hier gott so aber trotzdem kommt
man natürlich in dieser kämpfer in diese
fragen rein wenn man selber dermaßen
davon betroffen ist das stimmt und in
diesem sinne gibt es ja nicht nur lob
zahlen sonst gibt nach klage zeigt die
persönliche frage glaube ich ist eine
ganz ganz wichtige frage aber um aus den
anfang noch mal zurückzukommen
es ist eine schlechte technologie wenn
man jetzt in diesem moment sozusagen
jemand der sich sonst nie mit diesen
fragen befasst hat der spiritualität so
nicht wichtig ist ja jetzt sehen wir nun
gut das ist es sind erfahrungen durch
die ganze religionsgeschichte hindurch
die menschen gelitten haben unter
krankheiten aber auch unter menschen
gemachten einem schwierigen dingen und
das heißt wir müssen bedenken die
freiheits fähre des menschen auf der
anderen seite müssen wir bedenken dass
diese welt eine fragile sache ist und
das heißt wir können nicht ein ganz
einfaches thema haben
der allmächtige gott der steuert das
waren nie so in diesem sinne würde ich
diese art von theologie würde ich sagen
die ist wirklich nicht hilfreich in
dieser situation
sie sprechen damit schon schon etwas an
das mich auch interessiert wie geht denn
jetzt die religion mit dieser
krisenerfahrung konkret um das ist ja
auch für sie persönlich natürlich als
pfarrer ein thema aber nicht nur auch in
den predigten die sie auch sie streamen
auch über youtube die sie da haben die
gehen sie genau mit einer solchen krisen
erfahrung um oder religion insgesamt ich
glaube wichtig ist und so haben wir
versucht zu gewerke hier und das ist das
natürlich ein schock ist das her kein
karfreitag keine ostergottesdienste
feiern kann
alle die leute gekommen sind und da in
den letzten jahren und das erwartet
haben die müssen jetzt zu hause bleiben
wenn man uns versucht etwas zu überlegen
in dem sinne dass wir gesagt haben ich
telefoniere beispielsweise sehr viel mit
menschen
sie an und sagt wie geht's fällt ja
quasi die decke auf den kopf dass das
eine und das andere ich habe versucht
über videosequenzen mit schöner musik
leben auch mit einer art von von
besinnung von einer zuspruch ihnen etwas
mitzugeben nach hause und so diese
kommunikation haben für euch zu haben
aber erwarten die leute denn dass diese
situation auch als religiöser sich
gedeutet wird und wenn ja was bieten sie
ihnen daran dass ich weder beim thema
von zuvor
ich habe jetzt ganz konkret habe ich
versucht obwohl wir in der passionszeit
sind eben nicht nur über das leiden zu
sprechen sondern ich habe über die
sieben tugenden gesprochen
das heißt tapferkeit aber nicht nur
tapferkeit so nach besonnenheit auf der
anderen seite über gerechtigkeit zu
sprechen aber nicht nur gerechtigkeit
auch weisheit und dann glaube hoffnung
liebe
das heißt ich versuche hier ein bisschen
und das ist gute religion hilft
sozusagen in dem das wir orientierung
suchen und über orientierungs fragen
miteinander sprechen diesem sinn habe
ich versucht orientierungs angebote zu
machen sowie das gute gottesdienste tun
sie sprechen die seele an aber sie
sprechen auch den kopf an woraus
schöpfen sind in ganz persönlich
hoffnung in dieser zeit auch ich schöpfe
hoffnung als im gottesglauben und das
heißt dass diese welt nicht einfach ein
sinnloses getriebe ist sondern das ist
in diesen das ist hinter dieser welt in
dieser welt mittendrin das göttliche
gibt und das heißt dass wir wenn wir in
uns gehen dass wir auch eine stimme
hören können die uns gutes zuspricht die
uns hilft nicht egoistisch zu werden
sondern auf andere menschen zuzugehen
in diesem sinne schöpfe ich hoffnung
darauf wirklich daraus dass ich
gott ist durch alle schwierigkeiten
hindurch wendet er sein gesicht uns zu
und wir sollten uns hinzu wenn man hat
ja zuvor gerade gesehen wie sie von
lehrern kirchenbänken gottesdienst
gefeiert haben und eigentlich ist es
doch so dass dort die gemeinschaft so
was wie die essenz ist also unglaublich
wichtig trotzdem hatten hatten sie
niemanden da was hat diese lehre mit
ihnen gemacht
also ich habe mir vorgestellt und das
ist ja auch die realität wenn ich jetzt
spreche das sind ganz viele leute nach
dabei sitzen vor dem fernseher oder vor
dem computer und kommunizieren mit mir
in diesem sinne hilft uns auch jetzt in
dieser schwierigen zeit hilft uns dass
sie solche technischen möglichkeiten
gibt sie sehen ich versuche es wiederum
positiv zu drehen natürlich wer so viel
schöner
wir könnten gottesdiensten für münster
feiern wir könnten gottesdienste in
unseren kirchen feiern aber im moment
können wir das nicht und ich glaube wir
sollten wirklich in diesem punkt
besonnen seien nicht nur top sondern
heißt es gibt regelungen die im moment
sehr sinnvoll sind und da sollte man
sich nicht selber als experte auf
spielen sondern sagen ja ich halte mich
daran
aber dann kann ich kreativ werden die
weise wie gehe ich mit dieser situation
um wie gesagt wir versuchen die
kommunikation zu verstärken
irgendwie gefragt wenn man jetzt diese
bilder von leeren kirchen sieht es ist
irgendwie trostlos ich habe mich aber
gefragt könnte es nicht sein dass das
auch ein blick in die zukunft sind die
kirchen leeren sich ja tatsächlich jetzt
sind sie zwangs mäßig leer wie sehen sie
das könnte das ein blick ein trostloser
blick in die zukunft sein
ich glaube es ist eine seltsame die sie
jetzt gerade weil also erstens mal kann
ich sagen wenn wir im frühjahr münster
gottesdienst feiern kommen viele
sollte das zweite ist ich bin mir
absolut gewiss dass wenn diese krise
vorbei ist wieder viele leute kommen
werden ich glaube so gar nicht mit not
lehrt beten theologie rich glaube dass
wieder mehr leute sensibel werden diese
großen fragen des menschseins und diesem
sinne spirituelle fragen für sich
ausnehmen durchdenken und dann
vielleicht die angebote anschauen da bin
ich auch nicht so wie soll ich sagen
traurig gestimmt oder so zweifelhaft
gestimmt dass menschen diesen großen
schatz des religiösen wieder intensiver
wahrnehmen
sie zeichnen das jetzt aber insgesamt
zuvor eigentlich ganz schön sie sagen
sind sie sind schauen besondern darauf
ich frage mich trotzdem wenn man diese
übertragungen live übertragungen von
gottesdiensten sieht oder via internet
oder tv oder radio fehlt da nicht das
wesentliche natürlich einerseits die
gemeinschaft ist nicht da aber man ist
selbst nicht teil davon ich möchte da
nur kritisch nachfragen
fehlt eigentlich nicht das wesentliche
wenn man sich das alles nur eben aus dem
sessel anschaut
natürlich fehlt die konkrete
gemeinschaft aber wenn wir jetzt noch
mal zurück denken und das was der papst
gemacht hat franziskus war unglaublich
nahe die worte haben diese distanzen
überwunden und dadurch dass er wirklich
auch wichtige dinge gesagt hat wurde
plötzlich kommunikativen eher möglich in
diesem sinn will ich da nicht so
skeptisch
und wie ist es damit dass jetzt in
dieser krisenzeit die kirche neben als
zufluchtsorte nicht bestehen können wo
leute eben genau diesen wunsch hatten
bei uns ist es so dass wärme ist offen
wo wir anfangen keine gruppen oder
einzelne kommen hinein und suchen innere
ruhe besinnung wohl in sich gehen
in diesem sinne ist das durchaus nicht
so dass wir die kirchen schließen aber
auch diese pandemie vorschriften und das
ist auch das einzig sinnvolle ja ein
katholik hat in hessen aber dagegen
geklagt dass ebendieses gottesdienst
verbot jetzt besteht und das wird jetzt
vor ostern noch quasi entschieden
gut ich bin kein corona experten
ich finde es ein bisschen seltsam also
wenn man versucht menschen gruppen zu
schützen und sagen jetzt im moment sind
gottesdienste gefährlich dann sollte man
keine klagen machen das ist mein recht
ich darf das sondern muss man auch
experten vertrauen aber
selbstverständlich sollten wir darüber
sprechen und dann auch unterschiedliche
experten hören die sagen dass wir jetzt
wieder öffnen können und dann werden wir
das tun werden sehr fröhlich sehr
dankbar wieder gottesdienste feiern
corona wir hören dass jetzt schon aus
dem ganzen gespräche heraus ist ja die
krankheit eigentlich auch der einsamkeit
viele menschen sind alleine können sie
gut alleine sein
also wenn sie so persönlich sagen ich
bin nicht der spezialist für uns alleine
sein aber ich glaube dass es genau die
chance dass seelsorge ist dass man leute
nicht alleine lässt die listen sie würde
ich sagen menschen suchen trost und
trost sucht man dann wenn man selber
nichts mehr machen kann wenn man aktiv
ist machen kann und so dann sucht man
nicht tust aber wenn man plötzlich merkt
mit meinem machen ist es radikal zu
ähnlich muss dinge hinnehmen
dann ist es wichtig dass jemand mit mir
spricht und das ist seelsorge und
tröstlich sprechen heißt dann jemandem
das gefühl hat ich bin ganz alleine oder
raum entweder die perspektiven ganz
klein werden jemanden dann im gespräch
zu zeigen du hast auch andere erfahrung
gehabt
es werden wir dann nachher zeiten kommen
dass
räume öffnen geistige räume öffnen mit
menschen zu sprechen dass sie merken das
was mich sozusagen um mich selber
kreisen lässt obwohl es konkret ja
frauen sind das ist nicht das definitiv
sondern man kann versuchen anders damit
umzugehen
ich merke einfach wenn ich leute anrufer
am telefon wie dankbar sie sind und wie
sich im gespräch etwas öffnet etwas
entwickelt ich habe das ist seelsorge
trotzdem wenn man jetzt so die ganze
zeit zu hause ist also sie sagen sie
aber sie sind nicht experte im alleine
sein heißt es dass sie schon auch in
dieser zeit gemerkt haben dass sie so
ein gefühl von einsamkeit oder eben
alleine sein hatten ja das ist so also
man wünscht sich natürlich das ist nicht
eine zunge ab schließung und einsamkeit
ist dass das wieder vorbeigeht
aber eben es gibt auch gute
möglichkeiten damit kreativ umzugehen
beispielsweise dass man plötzlich wieder
dinge zu lesen beginnt um richtig viel
zeit hat schöne große bücher liest oder
musik wieder hört in großer
konzentration und ich durch den nächsten
termin schon abgelenkt ist
ich glaube solche chancen wahrnehmen das
hilft auch einsamkeit überwinden und
dann natürlich auf andere nicht zu gehen
weil man das im moment nicht kann aber
eben e mailen chatten telefonieren und
in diesem sinn diese kommunikation
aufrecht war und jetzt ist auch so dass
kranke im spital ganz extrem hat ganz
extrem hat man das auch aus italien
gelesen
die sind dort ganz alleine oft niemand
darf mehr zu ihnen gehen der priester
mit drehte angeschrieben aber ganz in
seiner schutzmontur steht vielleicht vor
einer solchen plexiglaswand wie wir hier
zwischen uns haben und leute sterben
alleine
davor haben wir alle angst und es stellt
sich doch die frage wie kann man in
solchen situationen noch menschlich dem
tod
begegnen oder der mensch menschen
menschlich dem tod begegnen lassen
also ich glaube es eine extreme
situation und was hier schildern ist
natürlich wirklich so dass jemand
aufgrund dieser gefährlichen krankheit
isoliert ist immer schon das faktum dass
ein priester da ist oder dass ein
fahrerin oder der fahrer kommt auch wenn
eine maske an hat heißt doch gewiss
nicht ganz alleine
ich glaube in diesem sinne müssen wir
unter extremen bedingungen versuchen das
möglich zu machen was möglich ist
letztlich aber müssen wir auch
akzeptieren glaube ich dass man alleine
stirbt
und das heißt dass der letzte wegstrecke
ist eine die man selber gehen muss in
diesem sinne kann wir können wir
eigentlich nur wenn man jemandem zeigen
ich lass dich nicht im stich aber diesen
letzten weg der musste eingegeben haben
sie denn leute jetzt im spital schon
besucht also mit corona nicht aber
andere natürlich schon weil ich jetzt
noch keine solche anfrage bekommen habe
aber ich werde heute nachmittag jemanden
besuchen gehen sterben liegt das gehört
zu meinen aufgaben und das sind auch oft
eindrückliche erfahrung
denn es sind nicht immer notfallstation
situation
es gibt eine ganze palette von
unterschiedlichen situationen und
tatsächlich ist es so wir sind
verletzlich gewesen wir sind endlich
gewesen
jeder muss sich damit irgendwie befassen
dass diese stunde kommen wird dann ist
wichtig dass man nicht nur das negative
sieht sondern dass man dann auch sieht
zeit geschenkt zu bekommen die aber auch
endlich ist das ist zuerst einmal etwas
schönes diese zeit aktiv zu leben und
dann vielleicht auch darüber
nachzudenken was wir andere jetzt mit
dieser zeit noch machen können wie wir
sie produktiv einsetzen können
miteinander einsetzen können nicht für
blöd sind sowie für ich dir gesagt
gewisse gemeinden in zürich haben mir
beispielsweise turmbläser jetzt oder
christoph siegrist hat von karl sturm
spricht einen segen über die ganze stadt
ich habe mich dann gefragt kann man
eigentlich nächstenliebe aus dieser
sicheren distanz wirklich praktizieren
ja ich glaube das kann man also ich
komme noch einmal auf den papst zurück
ich glaube wenn man deutlich macht durch
technische mittel hindurch dass wir
menschen nicht isoliert gewesen sind
nicht individuen dann kann man eine
herstellen
er stellt sich hier durch gute musik
näher stellt sich hier durch gute worte
durch tröstlicher wollten in diesem sinn
glaube ich ist ganz wichtig dass wir
jetzt mit einem den appell hören denn
diese krise in uns auslösen kann
was down under nicht im stich geht
aufeinander zu im sinne von noch mal
schreibt
schreibt eine karte zeigt euch
gegenseitig dass ihr verbunden sei ganz
konkret trifft es natürlich auch leute
die überhaupt keinen zugang zum internet
haben was was macht man mit menschen die
nicht online gehen kann ebenso ein
gottesdienst nicht online streamen
können man kann sie zwar anrufen aber
mit einem anruf vielleicht pro woche ist
man ja nicht per se weniger einsam kann
man beispielsweise was wir jetzt gerade
gemacht haben ich habe gestern nacht
habe ich die letzte predigt habe ich
ausgedruckt und die werden wir und leute
auf papier verschicken von denen wir
wissen dass sie keine e-mail haben
da bekomme ich viele echt aus weil die
leute dankbar sind dass fliegt etwas ins
haus hinein als ein stück hoffnung ist
dadurch dass das heißt ja ich bin immer
ungefähr münster gewesen aber jetzt
bekomme ich wenigstens eine predigt dass
in diesem sinn auch der versuch ein
bisschen kreativ damit umzugehen was ich
bei ihnen insgesamt schon auch raus höre
ist diese krise als chance auch
verstanden das hört man von
verschiedenen leuten für gewisse leute
ist das aber natürlich nur eine phrase
weil sie man weiß das ja auch weil
derzeit innerfamiliäre ausschreitungen
natürlich zunehmend auf grund dessen
dass man auf so engem raum die ganze
zeit zusammen ist es gibt konflikte und
letztlich glaube ich auch da kann man es
positiv werden an das heißt wenn ich
bereit bin mit jemandem konflikt
auszutragen zeige ich ihm du bist
wichtig ich lasse dich nicht einfach
weggehen sondern wir streiten darüber
aber wir versuchen auch eine mögliche
basis für die zukunft hinein zu finden
und in diesem sinne glaube ich sollte
man auch da den versuch machen das
positiv zu sehen
das heißt nicht die krisenstimmung zu
gehen nur blaulicht modus sondern auch
sehen moment habe ich die möglichkeit so
oder so zu reagieren
ich versuche gut zu reagieren sagen sie
mal herr peter mit trost für gläubige
menschen das habe ich jetzt irgendwie so
verstanden bei ihnen da haben sie
einiges anzubieten was macht man mit
menschen die nicht gläubig sind in einer
solchen zeit
woraus schöpfen die trost ich glaube
ganz wichtig ist dass man nicht sondern
die frage stellt bist du gläubig oder
mich sondern dass man zuerst einmal die
grundsätzliche menschliche verbundenheit
sid und wenn ich das spüre dass jemand
auf mich zukommt dann bin ich bereit und
dann ist es sehr schön wirklich auch
zuzuhören was die elemente sind die
diese person sagen lassen also mit
glauben habe ich schwierigkeiten auf der
anderen seite finde ich auch man sollte
leute nicht mit glauben in
anführungsstrichen belästigen wenn sie
sagen ich möchte das nicht man muss
sensibel sein muss will ich das gefühl
haben man sei für alle zuständig und
muss offen sein
manche prophezeien ja nach dieser krise
wir kommen da eigentlich in beschließen
den kreis eine gewissermaßen geläuterten
wert andere sagen sobald dieser schotter
und vorbei ist nach dem ersten tag wird
die band der ganze die ganze konsumwut
egoismus und so weiter wird wieder
hervorbrechen sehen sie das ich bin kein
prophet aber sie machen sich trotzdem
wählt einfach internetzugang und ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt so lese wie die
einzelnen leute das deuten und so ich
glaube man sollte denen zu hören die aus
einer soll ich sagen guten perspektive
heraus sprechen und die nicht sozusagen
den teufel an die wand malen
mit dem sie ja noch schlimmer werden und
so nein ich glaube wir haben viele dinge
in der hand und wir können jetzt im
moment doch darüber nachdenken wie wir
wenn das ganze sich wieder lockern wird
die wir auf eine gute weise dinge die
wir vernachlässigt haben jetzt neu
bedenken können es gilt für das
wirtschaften
das gilt für die beziehungen es geht für
ganz verschiedene aspekte des
menschseins diesem sinne denke ich gut
wenn man sagt ich krise schüttelt mich
durch aber dieses wissen geschüttelt
werden
das ist eine chance zu sagen was
eigentlich wichtig im leben
wie gestalte ich jetzt mit anderen
menschen zusammen die zukunft auf eine
weise in der wir vielleicht dann besser
vorbereitet sind sollten nochmal solche
krisen kommen in der die strukturen
vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser
vorbereitet sind
obwohl man sagen muss eigentlich ist bei
uns ist vieles gut gelaufen also ich bin
nicht jemand der sagt man hat das
verpasst das verpasst und so sondern die
schritte waren überlegt sie waren
besonnen und man hat die bevölkerung in
die kommunikation mit hineingenommen ist
ganz wichtig aber trotzdem denken sie
dieses reflexion moment das jetzt
ansprechen der das nachhaltig sein
ich glaube es wird nachhaltig sein
das heißt wenn ich so spreche wenn ich
ein mensch der hoffnungsvolle ist und
ich glaube es ist eine chance aber so
richtig garantieren kann ich das nicht
ich nehme sie hat auch kein prophet
ich bin ein fahrer scheint dann and mir
mit dieser hoffnung ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlicher peter für dieses gespräch
auch ihnen danke ich dass sie dabei
waren
weiter diskutieren können sie auf meinem
twitter oder instagram kanal jetzt
gleich geht es in der sternstunde
philosophie darum was corona über die
politik verrät und ob das virus an
stress test für die demokratie ist bis
demnächst bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]